[Applauso]
[Musica]
guardiamo insieme un attimo questa
immagine e ditemi cosa ci vedete
Ci vedete due cantanti ci vede bene
prima buona notizia seconda notizia
questi due cantanti
Stanno cantando giusto Ok
in realtà ragazzi Quello che non vediamo
È che entrambi non sono mai stati a quel
concerto perché quando acquistiamo
assistente un'immagine generata
dall'intelligenza artificiale La cosa
curiosa che non è alterata
modificata Ma è proprio generata
partendo da una stringa di testo crea
una foto di Elvis Presley che sta
cantando all'interno di uno stadio
estremamente semplice generale le
immagini così
ora per alzata di mano che devo usare
l'intelligenza artificiale per tre ore
al giorno al lavoro vediamo un po'
per almeno tre ore dai
e proviamo
Chi di voi usa Amazon music
Guardate cosa succede se cambio un
pelino la domanda Chi di voi usa Google
Hai visto che succede
Allora vedete il tema è che
l'intelligenza artificiale è dentro
questi software già da un sacco di tempo
non è arrivata adesso ma allora perché
se ne sta parlando così tanto
perché per la prima volta nella storia
una società americana Open Air ha
permesso a qualunque sviluppatore al
mondo di integrare l'intelligenza
artificiale all'interno dei propri
software ok Questo significa
che da adesso la i entra in tutti i
nostri device Che diventeranno
intelligente
che tradotto significa che inizieremo a
parlarci e a casa mia quando inizia a
parlare con le cose non butta bene
in realtà quello che sperimenteremo da
qui a breve Infatti l'abbiamo già visto
pensate al navigatore satellitare gli
dici Mi porti da un punto a un punto b e
lui ti porta ok
cosa succede che sbaglia strada a me
capita spesso e quando sbaglia la strada
cioè capita che tu non gli dai retta e
ti lamenti no fai tipo a causa di giro
vi sta facendo fare
Cioè ti lamenti gli dai retta c'è
proprio come mia moglie le chiavi
E allora Vedete se il navigatore Ci fa
dimenticare le strade
è accaduto anche un'altra cosa di
recente pensate i numeri di telefono chi
si ricorda più gli ultimi 5 numeri in
rubrica Messi e suo però prima degli
smartphone tutti ci ricordavamo i numeri
di telefono perlomeno ce ne ricordavano
tantissimi ora non ci ricordiamo più
niente quindi se il navigatore
satellitare non ci fa più ricordare le
strade se lo Smartphone non ci fa più
ricordare i numeri di telefono
qual è il problema anche perché il punto
è che non accade per caso questa
faccenda succede Perché il nostro
cervello preferisce risparmiare risorse
cioè quando può preferisce non
appesantirsi dovendosi ricordare tutto
preferisce delegare
E allora in questo scenario dobbiamo
entrare capendo che sono già tantissimi
device che oggi ci dicono cosa fare
faccio un esempio
lo SmartWatch Chi di voi se l'è comprato
e dopo aver comprato ha detto Ah guarda
mi può avvisare quando per bere acqua
poi c'è quello che dice no perché mi
dice quando mi devo alzare dalla
scrivania in ufficio quindi usi lo
Smartphone per ricordarti della
scrivania poi c'è lo smartphone cosa
fare infatti dice continuamente a cosa
devi stare attento ti dice stia attento
a questo se attenta a quest'altro
gestisce la nostra attenzione poi ci
sono i dispositivi vocali Siri Alexa che
ti ricordano quando accendere le luci
che ti suggeriscono quando devi
ascoltare musica e questo che significa
significa che
l'intelligenza artificiale è già dentro
le nostre giornate ci abbiamo già a che
fare e forse abbiamo anche superato una
soglia aggiungo io perché
mentre siamo qua questo ve lo dico per
capire il livello non me ne vogliate
sul sito tua moglie è arrabbiata.it
ok C'è chi si sta allenando a
bisticciare con la moglie utilizzando il
sistema di intelligenza artificiale
con la moglie usando gli ultimi
risultati anni di evoluzione sprecati
anni di evoluzione sprecati
[Musica]
allora
Il punto è che in questo momento
abbiamo
varcato una soglia mai vista nella
storia siamo pieni di strumenti
straordinari o perlomeno oggi è
possibile avere strumenti straordinari
immaginari di bisticciare di allenarsi a
bisticciare con la moglie fa ridere Ma
cosa accade se trasliamo uno strumento
di questo tipo in ambito aziendale e
magari lo mettiamo a disposizione della
gestione del conflitto di un tema
caldissimo succede che per la prima
volta su una storia possiamo allenarci
in modo diverso a questa cosa
di cose ne stanno già succedendo
tantissime penso per esempio agli Atlas
della Boston dynamics che sono del robot
proprio dotati di gambe e di braccio che
si stanno allenando a fare tante cose
tra cui anche a sostituire i muratori
oppure c'è mi colpiva molto l'altro
giorno vedere già per punto a i un
software che assegna i punteggi Durante
gli incontri di boxe in tempo reale con
una precisione straordinaria meglio di
50 giudici messi insieme
qualcosa questo è facile le auto a guida
autonoma
che decidono se gira la destra se girare
a sinistra
sono già delle nostre strade Ecco a
riguardo per una domanda me la faccio
perché quando l'auto guida autonoma
Dovrà decidere magari perché freni rotti
di andare avanti mettendo a rischio la
vita di chi conduce l'auto può girare a
destra mettendo a rischio quella di tre
persone che fanno attraversando la
strada
di chi è di chi sarà questa
responsabilità
è questo che vi ho detto è già oggetto
il tema etico è già oggetto di
attenzione a livello mondiale Esistono
dei siti come moral machine.com dove le
persone di tutto il mondo vanno
a dare questo tipo di risposta e questa
risposta è verbo vengono aggregate
creando un enorme dataset che poi sarà
usato probabilmente da chi
commercializza le auto a guida autonoma
abbiamo vissuto in questi ultimi tempi
un passaggio straordinario che non ha a
che fare con quello che conoscevamo
tutti dal cacciavite l'affittatore a
batteria no
fermiamoci un attimo sto momento
bellissimo ti arriva il pacco a casa
dove solo appoggi
scattoni tutto ti metti con l'avvitatore
lì a manina io cintura nera di Mi fa
male il polso per favore salvatemi
magari si montasse da solo vado mi
compro la vetta della batteria
torno a casa tipo Rambo
avvitato sopra
il punto Qual è il punto è che ti
avanzano pezzi perché invece alla 06
quindi è ovvio che se mi immagino di
tirare su uno stesso opaco metterci a
fianco il mio bene avvitatore
intelligente sedermi magari di latte a
vederlo fare il lavoro la figata
pazzesca uno non avanza lo pezzi due
abbiamo tre mobile in fretta Treia non
mi ci svatto
però in questo scenario dobbiamo
includere Un passaggio importante ovvero
il momento in cui l'avvitatore si gira e
ti fa Magari anche con una voce
simpatica Scusa non è che mi passi le
viti
Ecco dobbiamo dirgli di no
perché da lui che lavora per te a Tu che
lavori per lui è un attimo
e questo l'abbiamo visto di recente
anche quando numerosissime Big Tech come
Google Amazon meta hanno licenziato
centinaia di migliaia di persone in
favore dell'intelligenza artificiale
abbiamo già varcato la soglia in cui
l'avvitatore si gira a chiederti di
passarli le viti
ed è licenziamenti avvenuti per via
dell'intelligenza artificiale Secondo me
ce n'è uno che li riassume tutti
ed è quello di Sebastian
che un ragazzo di Firenze che fa il
Rider
e che durante le ore di lavoro vive
attendendo la notifica di quel robottino
che c'è nello smartphone e lì dice
quando deve consegnare cosa e a chi
questa lì Bel tempo brutto tempo pioggia
Qualunque sia la condizione lo
smartphone gli dice che deve partire il
robottino dice di andare e lui scatta
Perché sa benissimo che quel robottino è
super efficiente
sa se consegna quando consegna e a chi
consegna
Sebastian prende riceverà notifica e
corre durante questa corsa
incontra una macchina che purtroppo
lo prende in pieno
e in quell'occasione Sebastian ha perso
la vita
non ultima era il suo giro di consegna
e di giorno dopo ha ricevuto un'email da
parte dello stesso robottino alla
felicità prima
che li comunicava che era stato
licenziato
perché aveva mancato gli accordi
contrattuali non avendo terminato il suo
giro di consegna
lo stesso identico anno
l'anno scorso al 2022 Allah Jones
Hopkins University per la prima volta
nella storia un robot riesce a elaborare
un intervento di chirurgia
in totale autonomia
in totale autonomia mosso da
intelligenza artificiale
al Policlinico Gemelli dottor scambia
introduce Jugo che un software un robot
che si occupa di assistere il chirurgo
durante l'intervento di ginecologia
migliorando in maniera incredibile sia
quantità che la qualità degli interventi
ed è stato è stata la prima volta nella
storia che accadeva una roba del genere
in Europa
e ancora
senaf.org che lavora per rendere
finalmente accessibile il mondo e non
udenti
trasformando i suoni il linguaggio dei
segni
immaginate cosa vuol dire nascere Sordi
vivere Sordi a un certo punto capire
quello che ti circonda
oppure
Larry walks robotic che crea degli
esoscheletri che stanno permettendo alle
persone
di riprendere a camminare
E allora
l'intelligenza artificiale
è buona o è cattiva
Secondo me l'intelligenza artificiale
come il fuoco
per certo ci siamo evoluti grazie al
fuoco ma questo è accaduto Perché la
nostra intelligenza naturale
a un certo punto ha capito che per usare
bene il fuoco bisogna mantenerlo alla
giusta distanza
Quindi in sintesi io sono qua oggi per
dirvi se il bicchiere mezzo pieno o
mezzo vuoto
Però mi piacerebbe che tra 30 anni E
questo forse un po' il mio sogno
rivolgendomi alla più avanzata forma di
intelligenza artificiale al mondo
e domandandogli di cosa ha paura
lei mi possa rispondere che
teme gli esseri umani
ed in particolar modo quelli
intelligenti
Perché potrebbero Perché potrebbero
rubare i lavori
per chi di voi si stesse chiedendo cosa
c'entra questo Talk con la leggerezza
se si chiede tra intelligenza
artificiale
[Applauso]